[Music]
on this Monday night the prestigious
honor for a pair of pioneers the Nobel
Prize awarded to two scientists behind
coid 19 vaccines we collaborated and had
fun how their perseverance paved the way
for scientific
achievement shameful Secrets how did we
let the Nazis into this country the
calls to declassify documents on
suspected Nazis in Canada Donald Trump
back on trial they wasting everybody's
back the latest lawsuit and courtroom
drama and what the Republican front
runner stands to lose plus there's no
place like home I have to Pence myself
realizing the dream of home ownership on
a BC First
Nation global national with Donna
freezen reporting tonight Jeff simple
good evening and thank you for joining
us the Nobel Prize for physiology or
medicine was announced today awarded to
two doctors whose groundbreaking work
helped change the course of the co 19
pandemic their Decades of research paved
the way for the coid MRNA vaccines the
pair will now share a million dollars US
in prize money but for a long time they
struggled to get any grants and one of
them was even demoted our Europe bureau
chief Crystal ganing has the incredible
story behind the
science if you got an m RNA co9 vaccine
you're linked to the latest Nobel Prize
recipients for physiology or medicine
you can't have a better example of how
something became useful for the whole
world and for
Humanity after years of working solo
Catalin carero teamed up with Drew
wisman and together in 2005 they
developed what's known as the nucleoside
based modifications a way to prevent the
body's immune system from attacking
labade mRNA technology that fiser btech
and madna went on to use when they made
their mRNA Co 19
vaccines the duo now has multiple Awards
but Caro's Journey has been one of
persistence the Hungarian scientist
revealed her late mother would listen to
the Nobel announcements on the radio
believing her daughter could
win she said this when I had no
Professor job or no team I was only
working hard in the laboratory a fact
that makes the work all the more
impressive says this Canadian infectious
disease expert she did not get tenure
she did not win big grants she had her
papers rejected from journals of the of
the highest caliber and and she
persisted today the University of
Pennsylvania noted the brilliant
researchers who represent the epitome of
scientific inspiration and determination
Katie lit the match and and we spent the
rest of I don't know 20 plus years
working together figuring out how to get
it to work how to get a vaccine to
function well Dr Isaac bogos says
scientists all over the world struggle
to secure funding and ultimately human
health suffers this is a giant wakeup
call that it is so important to fund
good science and good scientists Crystal
ganing Global News
London the federal government is facing
growing calls to reveal secret details
about suspected Nazi Collaborators who
were allowed to enter Canada after the
second world war those calls come after
Parliament paid tribute to Urus laav
hunka last month even though he fought
for the Nazis Jewish leaders say what
started as an international
embarrassment could become an
opportunity to confront a shameful party
of Canada's past David aen reports on
the push to declassify the desan
report speak on behalf of all of us in
this house I would like to present
unreserved apologies for what took place
on Friday to many the prime minister's
apology should be the start of a renewed
Reckoning of Canada's history of
accepting former Nazis into the country
how we could possibly have such
indifference for Nazi perpetrators who
came to this country and there no
prosecutions and no deportations the
federal government has only once tried
to answer that question in the 1980s
after allegations were raised that
Canada had become a Haven for Nazi war
criminals the government convened
an inquiry headed by a Quebec judge
named juul desen the resulting desen
report did find evidence that no Nazis
had been admitted to Canada and new
legislation was passed to enable their
prosecution or deportation but part of
the desen report a part which contains
allegations about specific individuals
has never been made public get the
records open and tell Canadians what
really happened how did we let the Nazis
into this country and we are just not
going to move Beyond this Scandal until
that chapter is opened researchers
believe Canada admitted as many as 2,000
individuals who fought or worked for the
Nazis Jewish organizations say releasing
all of the desen report is crucial for a
full accounting there's opportunity here
for the for the government um to you
know open up the books and let's once
and for all you know bring this chapter
uh to a close by at least being
transparent at least sharing the
information asked to release all of the
desen report government ministers so far
have been non-committal as a government
we're going to be very thoughtful about
any further steps that need to be taken
a committee of MPS is expected to study
the issue when Parliament resumes next
week David Aken Global
[Music]
News European Union foreign ministers
are in keev for their first ever meeting
outside the borders of the 27 member
block they paid tribute to Fallen
Ukrainian soldiers and pledged to
continue their support for Ukraine that
meeting comes amid concerns about
growing funding fatigue from some of
Ukraine's allies over the weekend us
lawmakers stripped funding for Ukraine
from their short-term budget deal and as
Redmond Shannon reports some NATO
members have also announced plans to end
military aid
altogether awkward and icy Slovak
president Suzanna chaputa invites former
prime minister Robert fito to form a
government after Saturday's election
even as she is suing him for calling her
a US agent
allegations she says resulted in death
threats against her since topping the
polls fito has repeated his promise to
end all military aid to Ukraine if he
can form a coalition he was trying to
get also those voters who for whatever
reason have favorable attitudes towards
Russia particularly because of past
former Slovak foreign minister paval
demes says fitso will likely be forced
to compromise on Ukraine when courting
Coalition Partners if you look at
composition of our Parliament which will
comprise of seven political parties
Slovakia is far from being future
Hungary hungary's Victor Orban has not
sent any military aid to Ukraine and
Poland soon to go to the polls too is
threatening to stop over a grain dispute
with
keev but in the Ukrainian Capital Monday
fewer signs of European division EU
foreign ministers symbolically meeting
outside EU borders for the very first
time the block proposing billions more
in Aid and a plan to transfer Frozen
Russian assets to Ukraine aiming too to
shore up a United message on Russian
aggression for us Europeans allow me to
repeat it it's an
existential it's not just Europe where
cracks are appearing Washington's
short-term budget deal on Saturday
did not include Ukraine funds we are now
working with both sides of the Congress
to make sure that uh it does not repeat
again the Kremlin said Monday it expects
us Aid to Ukraine to continue but it
also expects fatigue to eventually set
in the results of the next us election
could determine whether that's true in
Washington and The Wider West Jeff
Redman Shannon in London thanks red
[Music]
no matter how powerful you are no matter
how much money you think you may have no
one is above the
law the Civil fraud case against former
US president Donald Trump brought
forward by New York's attorney general
Laticia James got underway in a
Manhattan courtroom today Trump is
accused of generating more than a
billion dollars by lying about his real
estate Empire on his way into court
Trump insulted New York's attorney
general the judge and called the trial
itself a sham but the case could have
serious implications for him and his
real estate businesses Joel senic
reports from
Washington former US president Donald
Trump defiant outside a New York City
courtroom Monday it's a disgraceful
trial put forward by an attorney general
who's corrupt Trump appearing in person
for the first day of a civil case that
could see him lose large parts of his
real estate Empire we're wasting our
time on this trial
with a Democrat judge from the
clubhouses it's a disgrace the former
president his two eldest sons and the
Trump organization are accused of
deceiving Banks and insurers by
inflating assets and misrepresenting the
size of properties the New York attorney
general is seeking at least $250 million
in fines and sat front row in court on
Monday Donald Trump and the other
defendants have committed persistent and
repeated fraud the law is both powerful
and fragile and today in court we will
prove our case the judge hearing this
case has already ruled Trump committed
fraud in his business dealings this next
phase will largely decide Financial
penalties one legal expert says this
voluntary in-person appearance could
make a difference in the final ruling if
the person has shown up in your court
that's telling you that they are paying
attention that could lead to Greater
leniency the former US president is is
facing several legal battles right now
he's been indicted four times since
March in four different jurisdictions
now Trump does not face any criminal
penalties in this New York case as it is
a civil one he is expected to testify
but not for weeks the judge says this
trial could run into December Jeff Joel
senic in Washington thanks
Joel Manitoba Party leaders are making
their final pitches to voters ahead of
tomorrow's provincial election that race
has seen record turnout at Advanced
polls more than 200,000 votes have
already been cast as Rosena hemple
reports the outcome is sure to make
history how do you
do I'm wob canu and I'm running to be
our Premier so we can fix healthc care
in Manitoba we will continue to provide
Manitoba with stability thanks to our
experienced PC team incumbent Premier
Heather Stephenson's been in power since
2021 and her Progressive conserv
conservatives have held a majority in
the province's legislature since 2016
with the latest opinion polling favoring
wob canoe and the new Democrats that
blue tide could turn orange I think we
can all be pretty confident that the NDP
is in the lead how much that lead is how
much it holds how much voters you know
might surprise us on Election Day Mary
Agnes Welch with probe research says the
PC's early campaign focus on
affordability is now being overshadowed
by wed issues in the last two weeks from
parental rights to the call to search a
landfill for the remains of two murdered
indigenous women those are some risky uh
risks to take in a campaign and I don't
know that they're going to pay off
Stephenson campaigning Monday focusing
on her party's experience tomorrow
manitobans the decision is up to you an
NDP who disregards the law raises taxes
puts Manitoba in debt and has no
experience
or an experienced PC team who will make
your life more affordable make streets
safer heal our Health Care system and
make our communities stronger Cano who's
been urging liberal supporters to cast a
ballot for the NDP instead isn't
straying from his focus on healthc care
if elected tomorrow the Manitoba NDP
will take immediate action to reduce
emergency room weight times in our
province by adding beds at the hospitals
with the remaining ERS but Manitoba
liberal leader dug Lamont saying his
party is the only one that can stop both
you can make sure that there's a
minority government and you are free to
make it happen by voting Manitoba
liberal there are historic storylines in
this election whether Manitoba stays
Blue or swings orange if Stephenson wins
she will be the first woman to be
elected Premier by manit toin if canoe
wins he will become the first first
nation's premier of a Canadian province
manitoban head to the polls on Tuesday
Rosanna hemple Global News
Winnipeg in a surprise move military
prosecutors have withdrawn their case
against leftenant General Steven whan he
had been accused of having an
inappropriate relationship with a
subordinate and improperly changing her
performance evaluation back in 2011 in
court whan wiped away tears as the final
charge was dropped in 2012 he was
removed as head of military personnel
Wayland's lawyers say he now plans to
take legal action against the government
for destroying his career catastrophe
strikes Sunday mass coming up a roof
caves in on a church full of
worshippers plus the world's greatest
gymnast makes history
again
a security camera captured the moment a
church roof collapsed in northern Mexico
on Sunday killing at least 10 people and
injuring dozens more including a baby
and young children Rescuers worked
through the night searching for another
30 people believed to be trapped in the
rubble it happened during a community
mass for a baptism ceremony it's not
known yet what caused that collapse
American gymnast Simone bil is once
again making history becoming the first
woman to land the yurchenko double Pike
vault
wow the 19 time world champion nailed
the landing at the artistic gymnastic
championships and that skill will now be
named the biles 2 in her honor this is
her first International competition
after a 2-year absence she pulled out of
several events at the Tokyo Olympics
citing difficulties with what's known as
the twisties a spatial disorientation
condition common in
gymnastics
economic reconciliation still ahead
indigenous business owners call for more
Capital welcome back many Canadian
businesses have struggled to survive
following pandemic restrictions and
closures and Indigenous business owners
say those challenges are Amplified by
systemic and economic barriers
indigenous entrepreneurs are now pushing
to improve access to capital for
communities and startups Nita gangal
reports on the push for economic
reconciliation Raven indigenous Capital
Partners is working to support
indigenous businesses often excluded
from the Western economy we founded the
firm in in 2018 um and it was really in
response to the lack of access to
Patient flexible Capital by indigenous
entrepreneurs um across Canada and the
United States in 5 years Paul desert's
fund has grown to $9 million investing
primarily in indigenous businesses we've
designed uh an entirely indigenous
approach where we look at indigenous job
creation indigenous governance
indigenous ownership the owner of one
company in their portfolio says his
investors values matter we need an
investor who believed in the same thing
as us it felt good to be able to work
with uh with people who uh really work
hard to to get money into uh indigenous
business
located on BC Sunshine Coast Aaron Joe's
waste management company has expanded in
recent years he says getting started 14
years ago wasn't easy for us we just uh
we started this business uh on reserve
and we rolled up our sleeves and and ran
off a shoestring budget indigenous
Business Leaders say the challenges
facing many business owners are systemic
indigen people have had barriers placed
in front of them legislatively
systemically in society that didn't
enable us to participate because we were
on reserve that we couldn't leverage our
land annual federal funding for
indigenous priorities has increased more
than
150% in the past 8 years but first
nation leader Charlene Gail says a lot
more needs to be done far too long we
just been left behind and I think that
having the indigenous loan guarantee
program will achieve that fairness and
our ability to to be involved
meaningfully a Federal Loan guarantee
program that deploys funds to more
sectors and greater private investment
could go a long way towards supporting
indigenous businesses very happy to see
the amount of healing that happens when
um there is a flow of capital the future
of the Canadian economy is that it's an
indigenous economy n ganguli Global News
Toronto home sweet home next how one
indigenous Community is taking back
power over how they
[Music]
live
Canada's housing crisis is being felt
across the country including in many
indigenous communities in northern BC
members of a First Nation are reflecting
on a unique piece of legislation it
allows them to individually own their
own homes nugara spoke with some Nisa
Nation residents about the push to own
property where is your
home behind the store over there this is
where 70-year-old Eric grandison lives
in most indigenous communities the
concept of home ownership doesn't exist
but here in Nisa Nation things are
different because of a treaty signed
more than 20 years ago they were the
first banned in BC to sign a modern
treaty and grandison says for him it
still feels surreal I have to Pence
myself every time I go home because I
can't believe that I actually own real
estate
I thought that I would die under the
Indian Act it was that pervasive under
that act all land on reserves is owned
by the crown Nisa is no longer under the
act and local leaders say it's helped
people take back power over how they
live our residents own their property
both the house and the ground that it
sits on uh through the uh land Holdings
act that legislation passed nearly 14
years ago but the idea of privatizing
these properties has been cause for
concern critics have said it puts
communities at risk of losing more of
their lands if sold to non-indigenous
buyers or seized by a bank when a
mortgage isn't repaid local leaders say
it's been a risk worth taking as far as
I'm aware there have not been any
mortgages that have been uh given back
uh they've been nobody defaulted nobody
has defaulted but there's a severe
shortage of adequate housing in
indigenous communities across Canada the
estimated cost to address the crisis in
First Nations alone is $135 billion the
Assembly of First Nations is working to
develop a national strategy with the
federal government we have to as First
Nations we have to learn how to fend for
ourselves the odds are
overwhelmingly stacked against you for
grandison a day school survivor he's
taking a moment to reflect on the
progress people in his community have
made even through so much pain and now
we're here we've come a long ways I'm
very proud of what First Nations are
doing today Nara Global News Nisa nation
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Jeff simple tonight's your
Canada is Triple Peak Mountain that's
near Port albery British Columbia we
love seeing your Canada so please keep
emailing your photos to viewers at
global na.com thanks for watching Donna
will'll be back with you tomorrow have a
great
[Music]
night